[Música]
Hola Esto es África 7 días el magazine
donde les presentamos la actualidad del
continente africano Mi nombre es amal
veloffman Y estos son los temas del
programa de hoy más de 43 años como
presidente Teodoro obviongo tiene el
récord mundial del mandatario que más
años ha estado en el poder el jefe de
estado ecuatoriano fue elegido para un
sexto mandato el 25 de noviembre es
conmemorado el día contra la violencia
de género en Nigeria existe una
herramienta contra este flagelo el
teatro les contaremos Cómo Es
aprovechada una retrospectiva la primera
en América del Sur está dedicada a la
pionera del cine africano Sara maldoror
esta muestra tiene lugar en la
cinemática de Bogotá y en ella se expone
la obra de esta mujer que practicó un
cine de combate hablamos con su hija
anushka de Andrade
lleva en el poder desde 1979 y acaba de
ser reelegido para otro mandato de 7
años en Guinea ecuatorial el único país
de África que habla español el
presidente Teodoro obiang Gema obtuvo el
94,9% de los votos según los resultados
oficiales quienes este controvertido
presidente africano veamos en el
siguiente informe
es un ritual
por sexta vez consecutiva el presidente
de Guinea ecuatorial fue reelegido con
más del 90% de los votos con 43 años en
el poder y a sus 80 años bate el récord
mundial de longevidad para un presidente
vivo
y justo antes de introducir su papeleta
en la urna se mostró seguro de su
Victoria
dice el refrán
lo que uno siembra es lo que cosecha
estoy segura de que
el partido PDF ha centrado mucho militar
de formación Teodoro biang nació en lo
que entonces era una colonia española el
3 de agosto de 1979 derrocó a su tío el
sanguinario dictador Francisco Macías
Gemma que fue fusilado dos meses después
Teodoro bianguima que nunca dejó el
poder mantuvo en vivo rumor a un golpe
de estado su Guardia pretoriana está
formada por soldados de su clan
supuestamente leales pero sus
guardaespaldas más cercanos son
israelíes y la seguridad del palacio se
Confía en parte a zimbabuenses y
ugandeses para evitar traiciones el
presidente tiene un control férreo sobre
el país los opositores son
sistemáticamente detenidos o exiliados y
las ongs condenan los graves abusos
contra los Derechos Humanos
Teodoro se benefició del descubrimiento
de petróleo en aguas territoriales a
principios de la década de 1990
Guinea ecuatorial se convirtió en el
tercer país productor de petróleo de
África y se enriqueció y la mayoría de
los 1.4 millones de habitantes siguen
viviendo Por debajo del umbral de la
pobreza Guinea ecuatoriales citada
regularmente por las ong es como uno de
los países con mayores niveles de
corrupción en los últimos años Teodoro
bianquema parecía estar prepara a su
sucesor uno de sus hijos el
vicepresidente teodorín conocido por su
lujoso estilo de vida pero por el
momento el Antiguo presidente ha optado
por conservar el poder
cambiamos de tema el 25 de noviembre es
conmemorado el Día Internacional de la
eliminación de la violencia contra la
mujer en la ciudad de lagos en Nigeria
se presenta durante 15 días una obra de
teatro para dar voz a aquellas que en el
curso de su vida han sido Víctimas de la
violencia por el simple hecho de ser
mujeres
en Lagos la capital de Nigeria el teatro
se transforma en la mejor defensa contra
los estragos que causa el sexismo desde
el 25 de noviembre día internacional de
la eliminación de la violencia contra la
mujer una obra refleja la capacidad de
resistencia de las mujeres al tiempo que
les permite relatar sus historias de
abusos machistas el reparto es
totalmente femenino y la violencia que
se describe no es ficticia se basa en
las experiencias de las mujeres
nigerianas
nada conecta con la humanidad como lo
hacen la poesía la música y el teatro
son vehículos maravillosos y formas de
llegar a la gente porque estas
conversaciones son muy serias y es
difícil conseguir que la gente hable de
cosas serias pero se puede lograr a
través de la música a través del teatro
es más fácil que la gente entienda
mientras entretiene y al mismo tiempo
estamos tocando el núcleo de su
humanidad y así consiguiendo su atención
para ello una de las actrices
principales de la obra considera además
que el problema de la violencia sexista
no afecta solo a las mujeres y que la
conversación debe dirigirse también a
los hombres
cuando la gente oye hablar de violencia
de género piensa primero en las mujeres
Los hombres también son maltratados los
chicos jóvenes Los hombres también son
violados están en relaciones abusivas y
el abuso tiene diferentes caras no
siempre es físicos
según las Naciones Unidas una de cada
tres mujeres ha sido violada durante su
vida por lo que los testimonios de estas
mujeres pueden servir para adoptar
enfoques globales e inclusivos que
aborden las causas de la violencia
transformar las prácticas sociales
rígidas y dar a las mujeres y las niñas
medios de acción
[Aplausos]
dejamos el continente en Nos dirigimos a
Bogotá la capital colombiana acoge a la
primera retrospectiva en Sudamérica
dedicada a la obra de La cineasta Sara
maldoror es considerada como la pionera
del cine africano viajó por todos los
continentes para acompañar las luchas de
liberación y defender un cine
comprometido y firmemente feminista y
anticolonialista para hablar de su
legado nos reunimos con su hija anushka
de Andrade en la filmoteca de Bogotá
Hola nos cae y muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros en Francia 24 estamos aquí
en la cinemática de Bogotá donde tiene
lugar la primera retrospectiva en
América Latina de la obra de su madre
las cineasta Sara maldoror entonces para
empezar a nunca podrías y hablarnos de
esta retrospectiva que nos muestra de la
obra de Sara maldoror bueno primero es
un honor de estar aquí de tener esta
conexión con Colombia particularmente
porque es aquí que estará hizo su última
película sobre la artista Ana Mercedes
Hoyos Y entonces está retrospectiva se
vea como un viaje a través de las obras
de Sara es una invitación de descubrir
más y más obras y también de dar una
idea del espectro de dentro lo cual
estará ha trabajado aquí América la
china pero también en el resto del mundo
y y cuál fue su manera de filmar sus
preocupaciones y para
justamente disfrutar un poco y compartir
sus obras Y por qué el legado de Sara
maldor es particularmente importante
para América Latina seguro Bueno yo creo
que es importante para todo el mundo
Sara abrió muchas puertas cuando ella
empezó en el compu del arte empezó a ser
directora de una compañía de teatro la
primera compañía de teatro negro en
Francia quizás en Europa en
1956 y luego se dedicó al cine y fue fue
un hay que darse cuenta que punto fue
difícil ser cineasta mujer y negra
en este contexto político general no
solamente en Francia que fue un país muy
racista Y
entonces ella logró superar todos los
obstáculos que tenía aquí enfrentar
porque y usted hoy trabaja en difundir
en proteger en restaurar la obra de su
madre porque diría que es importante hoy
seguir viendo y mostrando la obra de
Sara maldoro bueno es que durante sus
últimos años quizás los 20 últimos años
de su vida Sara Fue totalmente
invisibilidad nadie mostraba sus
películas fue muy difícil encontrarlas y
para ella que tenía todavía proyectos y
proyectos que le fue imposible seguías
trabajando así que los últimos películas
que ha hecho me tocó yo pronunciarlas
una producción así familiar y muy
chiquita pero hicimos las películas y
entonces
después de su muerte en 2020 yo no podía
quedarme así totalmente
invisibilidad yo sabía todo el trabajo
la representación de su trabajo así que
Me dediqué a preservarlas para que su
memoria sigue viva y para mí es muy
importante también
decidiera las nuevas generaciones Mira
este una mujer quien en su tiempo ha
hecho esto en estas condiciones abrió
caminos por favor siguen el amigo de su
madre al Gran poeta caribeño mcd le
dedicó estas palabras a Sara maldor que
con su cámara en el puño lucha contra la
opresión la alienación y desafía la
tontería humana era el cine la arma a su
madre
claramente y ella dijo que la cámara era
su arma y fue su manera de exprimirse su
madre trabajó entre África África del
Norte El Caribe América Latina creía
ella en la convergencia de las luchas de
los pueblos Bueno ella fue al final de
su vida un poco decepcionada por las
democracias y después de las
independencias africanas porque no era
totalmente una verdadera liberación de
los
antiguos colonialistas pero para ella
fue muy importante todo yo creo que lo
que nos quedamos de su obra es esta idea
de rescatar de rehabilitar toda todas
las culturas negras toda la contribución
que hicieron estas culturas por el mundo
entero y para Sara no había frontera
entre los hombres los países y tampoco
en su mente él ya estaba soñando y ha
contribuido un poco fue algunas semillas
para que
todos los humanos se hablaban se miraran
y y trabajan y colaboran más juntos
y cómo podríamos resumir su legado lo
que va a dejar a las nuevas generaciones
de luchadores que sea en América Latina
o en África Yo creo que la idea es no
tener miedo
seguir luchando ir por adelante no
importa que sea una mujer que sea de
cuál origen social o regionales de creer
en el poder de la creación yo creo que y
la fuerza de su trabajo es esto de ir
armas más allá de luchar contra todos
los prejuicios todos los temores las
paredes y
y seguir adelante por estar juntos y
Soñar en un mundo mejor este fue algo
pero todo con poesía y mucho humor
[Música]
Muchas gracias por estas palabras y por
haber estado con nosotros no muchas
gracias y por supuesto gracias a la
cinemática distrital por ofrecer Aquí
esta oportunidad de viajar a través del
cine absolutamente muchas así termina
esta edición de África siete días
Gracias por acompañarnos nos vemos la
próxima semana
[Música]